In this section, let's continue our review of core concepts with a quick look at Sequencer
fundamentals.
First, just a reminder that the Unreal Engine Non-Linear Editor and Assembly tool is known
as Sequencer, a tool that is used for ground-up shot creation, pre-visualization, full film
creation, game cinematic creation, and more.
Actors from the Outliner or assets from your Content Browser are added into Sequencer to
create level sequence assemblies.
Sequencer's user interface is shown here and broken into four distinct sections, and the
first section is right at the top.
That's the toolbar.
The toolbar area is where you will find several options like adding cine camera actors to
your level sequence using the camera icon.
The slate icon is used to open the movie scene capture or movie render queue for rendering.
You can also adjust your frame rate, toggle on or off the automatic keyframe option, save
your level sequence, or activate the curves editor, or more.
On the far right of the toolbar, you will find the breadcrumbs, which is a navigation
tool that lets you dive into any nested level sequence shot, make changes, and then navigate
back up to the original level sequence container.
Next, section number two, which is the Outliner.
This is where you can add or filter tracks in your level sequence.
It also acts as the event manager, allowing you to trigger events keyframed in the timeline,
which is section number three.
Located at the top of the timeline is the little red arrow known as the playhead.
Below the playhead is our tracks area, where every character, skeletal mesh actor, or static
mesh actor that needs to be animated, every audio track, shot track or camera attached
to the camera cuts track, or event trigger are all able to be keyframed.
Under that, at the bottom is section number four, the playback controls.
These can be used to play, pause, advance frames, loop playback, or even record a performance
with the built-in take recorder.
This is also where your time range slider exists, so you can adjust the view and playback
ranges.
So, now that you've been reacquainted with the Sequencer user interface, let's jump
into Unreal Engine and prepare for the animation in-engine exercises.
First up, let's move into the Content Browser, and located in the Courses folder, you will
find and select the SEQ20501 folder.
Inside that folder, you will find a Course Topics folder.
Inside the Course Topics folder, you will find a Hands-On folder.
And in that folder, there are two Topics folders, one for Anim Assembly and the other for Inverse
Solve.
Begin your preparations by opening the Anim Assembly folder and double-clicking on the
Anim Assembly Level Sequence.
This will open up the example for creating our first animation assembly.
This contains an SK mannequin and a few animation clips.
If you want to choose from any of the other animation clips to create your own track,
they are located in the Anim Clips folder.
Feel free to play around with your assembly.
Alright, that's it for this review section of Core Concepts, Sequencer Fundamentals, and
in the next section, let's review a few more Sequencer features and tools before we dive
into our Hands-On exercises.